bien sûr que la canicule c'est une
évidence elle a et on a tous en mémoire
évidemment ces périodes dramatiques ce
qui est certain c'est que moi je salue
la mobilisation de tous les services les
services évidemment hospitaliers on a vu
l'expression du ministre de la Santé et
de la ministre des Solidarités il y a
quelques jours pour rappeler évidemment
personne vulnérables de faire de compuls
prendre soin d'eux au maximum mais je
vous le rappelle la priorité a été et
l'urgence a été lancé désir par la
première ministre avec le plan canicule
qui avait été travaillé déjà en amont et
aujourd'hui et bien il faut accompagner
il faut accompagner avec beaucoup
d'humilité mais surtout faire attention
faire attention à ceux qui sont le plus
fragiles à ces canicules et encore une
fois les températures extrêmes que ce
soit des phénomènes extrêmes climatiques
c'est à la conséquence du changement
climatique ça ça s'accélère ça arrive de
plus en plus ça devient de plus en plus
intense et de plus en plus grave et
malheureusement ça se reproduit de plus
en plus de manière récurrente donc
faisons attention à ce qu'on aime aux
personnes les plus les plus fragiles et
pour ça les services évidemment de
l'État sont tous mobilisés et le
gouvernement aussi à leurs côtés